the voters in Burundi are going to the
polls in a crucial presidential election
that could see the first democratic
transfer of power in decades there now
this comes after five years of political
violence following the last election
over accusations that the result was
unconstitutional the corona virus could
also pose a threat to voter turnout fear
and currents ISA has ruled Burundi since
2005 but surprised many by not seeking a
fourth term his anointed successor every
Sunday ischemia is an Army General
considered as neither too close to the
government's alleged crimes nor as
someone who tried to stop them in other
words a compromise candidate I would
like to tell you that since Burundi's
founding no president has supported his
successor because I too have never
benefited from the support of my
predecessors that sentiment reflects
Burundi's tumultuous history in the
transfer of political power in Carranza
rose to the top in 2005 as the result of
a peace deal that ended over a decade of
civil war critics say his decision to
run for another five-year term in 2015
violated that deal the resulting
violence caused at least 1,200 lives
that's on top of hundreds of thousands
of deaths from ethnic strife in the
decades since it gained independence
from Belgium in 1962 landlocked Burundi
is one of Africa's smallest and poorest
countries the World Bank estimates that
75% of its 11 million people live in
poverty there's no money we are nothing
since morning we've just been sitting
here we're looking but we can't find any
customers
the UN has warned the government's
efforts to repress criticism could
trigger a new cycle of violence
in currents eases party and its youth
wing have been accused of rape torture
and murder rights groups say the
President himself has encouraged crimes
against humanity and campaigning has
gone ahead without regard for the corona
virus pandemic as has public life in
general critics accused the government
of covering up the true scale of the
public health crisis
something the winner of today's vote
might not have the luxury to ignore DWS
East Africa correspondent Sela and echo
is following this story for us joins us
now from Nairobi good day to you Sela
the run-up to this election has been
marred by violence how confident are
people that the voting will in the end
be fair well I spoke to some colleagues
on the ground in Burundi this morning
and they said that up to now things are
going normal they people are queuing up
they've been queuing up since 6:00 a.m.
in the morning the only thing that has
happened is that social media the media
channels seem to be blocked so people
are logging in via VPN but as you said
the election the run-up to the elections
has been marred by violence and there
have been reports of arrests of
opposition members arrests of
journalists there have been reports of
intimidation by the youth wing of the
ruling party as well as the police in
the military and and another thing is
that there are no international election
observers in the country at the moment
the East African Commission had trial
community had tried to send election
observers and up until last week they
thought they were going to do that but
they were told by the Burundian
government at the last minute that they
would be that they would have to
quarantine for two weeks and so they
could essentially not do their job so I
think that many analysts and observers
from the outside see this election as
not being free and fair okay what about
the corona virus how's that affecting
the turnout there's a lot of other
problems that you mentioned but what
about the pandemic how's that affecting
how voters are
to react well apart from the fact that
the election observers have not been
able to come there is there seems to be
it seems that very little effect on the
elections so far I mean the colleagues
on journalists on the ground told me
that the turnout has been good so far
this morning and I've seen pictures of
queues of people they have that they're
very there's very little social
distancing and there are a few polling
stations which seem to have hand-washing
facilities but other than that very
little I think has been done to chew and
to stop the spread of the virus if it's
there and it seems that people are not
stopping that is not stopping people
from going to the polls ok are we going
to see a change in in leadership will
there be a shift in power in the country
well that's the big question I mean P&Q
indeed a step is now stepping down after
15 years in office and during the 2015
elections he basically he basically made
sure that he could run for a third term
which is why the country rapid in
violence at that time but he has also
managed to make himself to make a pretty
good deal for himself so he's got a
healthy retirement package and he also
will get the title of supreme guide for
patriotism so the next government is
supposed to we'll have to consult with
him on matters of national security and
other important issues isola thanks so
much for that today from Nairobi